i was shocked
there is this guy lying on the ground
and he is not a danger to anyone
he's just lying there and two or three
officers are beating him with batons and
everybody is just standing around and
nothing is happening
i mean this was for me the paradigm
bad action how can you do that
it's a question at the heart of many
alleged police misconduct incidents
from the beating of rodney king in 1991
to the chokehold death of eric garner in
and the killing of george floyd in 2020.
why did other officers not intervene
the ideal is really simple
you stand up and do
something and sometimes something very
limited to stop a fellow officer
from doing unnecessary harm to someone
ervin staub is a psychologist who has
studied the concept of
active bystandership he first applied it
to policing after the rodney king
beating
now it's the foundation of a new version
of active bystander police training
created by georgetown university law
school's innovative policing program
called active bystandership for law
enforcement or
abel what brings us here today the able
training
since the murder of george floyd during
an arrest by minneapolis police
over 100 law enforcement agencies across
the u.s have signed on for the training
teaching police officers to intervene
against one another is a complicated
mission
the tradition is that police officers
are supposed to help each other
and support each other no matter what
so there is a very profound need to
change the culture
it's family i guess it's the simplest
way of putting it it's uh it's it's it
is
being an extended family there's loyalty
to my squad
loyalty to my subordinates my detectives
one of the themes i've already heard so
far this morning is loyalty we talked
about
when the call comes we go there's no
questions at a recent training in new
jersey for law enforcement agencies
across the state
officers began tackling this challenge
we are loyal to one another you've got
to be willing
to have a hard conversation with
somebody if you're loyal to them
if you really care about them you are
going to have that
integrity to not just have that blind
allegiance i think you need to be humble
i think you
need to learn um i think the biggest
problem that we have right now and
all this that's been going on is
this corporal restraining
that's what it comes down to the able
program seeks to go beyond previous
versions of active bystander
police training by teaching officers how
to overcome the psychological hurdles to
intervening
it's rooted in staub's experience as a
child in the holocaust
i was a six-year-old child in hungary
at the time when about 450
000 hungarian jews were
pushed into trained cars
taken to auschwitz and most of them
immediately killed
this woman who was taking care of us
took me and my sister into hiding
one thing that i learned from life
and also from research bystanders can be
very powerful influencing other
bystanders
and their behavior good morning guys
can we line up for an inspection
sergeant anthony lin has been with the
voorhees township new jersey police
department for nine years
he and his fellow officers recently went
through active bystander training
everybody's human everybody has their
moments and sometimes you just need to
be
reeled back a little bit so that you
understand that it's not a situation to
where
you want to be a snitch or be labeled as
a snitch but you want to make sure that
they get home safe we get home safe
if we've been honest with each other we
don't like changing law enforcement
right the training seeks to address
cultural change in a few key ways the
leaders and chiefs of agencies
are trained first and instructors are
members of the departments they train
get the class to talk about it get the
role players to talk about it
how did you feel about that what tactics
did you use
the participants in this class will
train officers in their respective
departments
there's some officers that would
interpret that intervention as
saying you're incompetent you can't you
can't handle it and
you know you need to have a cultural
component that says you know that's okay
it's okay to have somebody step in we
also train people to accept the
intervention
so you are learning how to intervene
first in as limited way as possible
and escalate as necessary
and how to accept training it's a hot
call so a lot of cops are showing early
in my career there was a occasion where
we had an arrest
i'm escorting them back to one of the
patrol cars and transferring back to
headquarters
uh one of the senior officers at the
time kind of stepped in and grabbed them
open the door and was
you know seemed like about to basically
slam the guy
in the door there thankfully a senior
officer was there and kind of intervened
and stepped in
but as i think back i should have said
something at that time it shouldn't have
to take someone else to step
in to intervene
the program also teaches officers to
look for allies when intervening
and you say to a fellow officer you know
this is bad
we should do something and then you
jointly take action
the creators of the abel program plan to
study data from participating agencies
to evaluate its effectiveness
the impact of other versions of active
bystander training
has been inconclusive the new orleans
police department reported a decrease in
civilian complaints
after participating in a previous
version of the training
but those results may have been
influenced by other reforms mandated
by the department of justice
[Music]
to have an impact the challenge for
staub and the able program
is not just to show how to intervene but
to make it acceptable to intervene
we have the ability to shift the culture
within ourselves and we have the ability
to
repair the trust with the community
we have to be able to protect ourselves
and sometimes
pull somebody back from potentially
harming someone else
or harming themselves it seems to me
like it's going to be a very important
tool going forward